2021 brought us a free brittany a space
race for billionaires and it turned
laura and raymond into tick tock stars
but it also brought us a completely
unhinged and discredited media if we had
listened to them instead of doing our
own research and questioning those in
charge things would be really different
here's just a few examples of what they
tried to get us to believe this year
critical race theory
it's a boogeyman
it's not even taught in most k-12
schools january 6 was worse than 9 11.
we know that the vaccines work well
enough that the virus
stops with every vaccinated person
joining me now is victor davis hanson
hoover institution senior fellow and
author of dying citizen uh
victor
i mean rachel maddow said it it must be
true that uh if you've gotten vaccinated
no chance it stops right there
yeah you know i don't want to be too
cynical jason but i don't think the
media exists as we once knew it it's
fused with the left-wing movement and
the democratic party and that's why
trump had not been in office more than
90 days and the liberal shorenstein
center at harvard said that 93 of the
coverage was biased against him and we
had prominent marquee journalists
christiane amanpour jim rittenhouse
jorge ramos they said they couldn't be
disinterested because of the trump
phenomenon and so if you would believe
the media then we we heard that andrew
cuomo was a professional and gifted
governor chris cuomo was a professional
journalist there was no relation between
the wuhan level four lab and the origins
of kova the chinese were very sober and
judicious in the way they handled the
the outbreak
uh we would we were told that and
somehow in waukesha there was an
autopilot suv that killed six people and
injured 62 but we didn't really know
much about the driver or what we were
told the written house trial where there
was white on white violence was some
simply about race and i i could go on so
they don't they don't feel that they
have to be and they should not be
disinterested the other thing they do is
they're a megaphone
for democratic talking points about
every three or four weeks they flood the
airways and the print media
with a theme and you remember when joe
biden went below 40 percent suddenly
democracy was in danger in 2022
2024 we could lose the country and they
had just told us it was very resilient
in electing joe biden and then we were
told that we might face a coup
and military officers were writing in
the washington post for example that
there was a danger of a coup in 2024
very ironic because there were people on
the left that had almost advocated a
coup if it was necessary to get rid of
donald trump then with joe manchin
suddenly as a renegade in the senate and
now we're flooded the last week with the
idea well the senate doesn't practice
equity it's an archaic ossified
institution we should it's not fair that
california doesn't get the same
numerical representation as wyoming even
though it's essential to the
constitution so i you know i was
thinking about this right now and you
know the one person one thing that uh
ben rhodes the former deputy
national security adviser to barack
obama said that was true about only one
thing he said that these people are 20
and 30 somethings that know nothing and
we create an echo chamber and we feed
them stuff and they reverberate it and
magnify it back and i think that's what
the media is it's not fair to call them
the media they're an extension of this
progressive movement
i i've got literally i've got 30 seconds
victor but if i said to you
what did joe biden actually do and
accomplish in 2021 can you really
honestly name anything
uh well i think he did one thing he
terrified the left because they had told
us he could campaign from the basement
it was only because of covet he was
completely
in control of his faculties and now they
look at the polling and the polling with
kamala harris that you've covered and i
think they're terrified and they're
starting for the first time to create a
scenario or landscape that suggests that
he's challenged because they're afraid
that he's going to take them down to
historic defeat
wow yeah
victor you're one of the smartest guys
uh i i we get to talk to you i thank you
for joining us here on the ingram angle
really do appreciate it have a wonderful
new year hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else